Du kannst hier reinschauen. Und du
kannst noch etwas näherkommen. So.
Jetzt gibt es vier Fotos.
Ist gut?
Ja.
- Also. Dann starten wir.
* Leicht melancholische
Klaviermusik *
(Mann)
Es ist uns eine grosse Ehre,
dass wir heute Thomas Zurbuchen
hier bei uns haben.
Er ist der wissenschaftliche
Direktor der NASA
und ist damit auch Herr
über 7 Mrd. $.
Er hat hier studiert und dann
beschlossen, in die USA zu ziehen.
* Applaus *
Es ist eine kleine Bühne
für Thomas Zurbuchen,
den Forschungsdirektor der
amerikanischen Raumfahrtbehörde NASA.
Zurbuchen gilt als einer der
mächtigsten Wissenschaftler weltweit.
In seiner Wahlheimat Amerika verkehrt
er mit den höchsten Politikern,
wie hier
mit dem Vizepräsidenten Mike Pence
bei der Besichtigung
einer Weltraumsonde.
Auch in der Schweiz kommen inzwischen
viele Menschen zu seinen Auftritten.
Eine Bilderbuchkarriere,
die jedoch nicht
nach den Vorstellungen seiner Eltern
verlief.
Was meinen Sie:
Ihre Eltern, wären die heute hier?
Ich nehme es nicht an.
Nein. - Meinen Sie,
sie wären nicht gekommen?
Nein, meine Geschwister
sind auch nicht da.
Nein, sie wären nicht gekommen.
Sie sind nie gekommen.
Als Sie an der Uni waren, waren sie
auch nicht an der Promotionsfeier?
Nein, sie sind nie gekommen.
Es war so eine fremde Welt für sie.
Ich sage immer: Wir sind zwar
auf dem gleichen Planeten,
aber in einer anderen Welt.
Nicht nur seine Karriere, auch
seine Biografie ist aussergewöhnlich.
Aufgewachsen ist er im Bergdorf
Heiligenschwendi, im Berner Oberland.
Sein Vater war strenggläubiger
Prediger in einer Freikirche.
Sohn Thomas hätte
in seine Fussstapfen treten sollen.
Aber er wählte
einen ganz anderen Weg.
Er entschied sich
für die Wissenschaft.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Vor Kurzem waren Bundesratswahlen.
- Ah ja?
Wissen Sie,
wer die neuen Bundesrätinnen sind?
Irgendeiner,
der nicht Englisch kann.
Nein, es sind zwei Frauen.
- Ah ja, sicher? Super.
Früher kannte ich natürlich alle
Bundesräte. Jetzt nicht mehr so.
Wie fühlt es sich an in der Schweiz?
Immer, wenn ich hier bin,
fühle ich mich zu Hause.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich ...
Ich bin über 20 Jahre weg,
aber ich kenne noch alles.
Was muss ich? Einen Ausweis zeigen?
- Ja, so etwas.
Das ist ein Führerausweis.
- Das ist ein Führerausweis.
Aber kein amtliches Dokument.
- Das ist ein amtliches Dokument.
Vom Staat Virginia in Amerika.
- Ja, aber in der Schweiz nicht.
Ich habe kein Schweizer Dokument.
Oder das hier?
In Amerika bin ich es gewohnt,
dass Politiker
von einer riesigen Security
umgeben sind.
Und an meiner Tür hat es Leute mit
Waffen, wenn ich zur Arbeit gehe.
Ich bin es gewohnt.
Wenn ich zu Ihnen käme
mit dem Schweizer Führerausweis ...
Keine Chance.
Man muss sich eine Woche vorher
anmelden, damit alles sicher ist.
Dann geht es schon.
Im Medienzentrum des Bundes
findet unser erstes Interview statt.
Das zu organisieren
hatte Wochen gedauert.
Rund 20 Personen kümmern sich
um Zurbuchens volle Agenda.
Er ermöglicht faszinierende Einblicke
in die Weltraumforschung.
Und das ist gefragt.
Für mich geht es wirklich darum,
besser zu verstehen,
wie die Natur funktioniert.
Für mich ist die Natur
eine der schönsten und wichtigsten
Sachen unseres Lebens.
Man merkt es, wenn man
in der Schweiz auf einem Berg steht
und hinunterschaut. Man sieht: Es
ist wichtig und unglaublich schön.
Und ein Forscher wie ich
sieht die Schönheit noch mehr.
Viel mehr Dimensionen
dieser Schönheit.
Die Geheimnisse des Universum
verstehen.
Wir wollen z.B. herausfinden,
wie das Leben auf der Erde
entstanden ist.
Die Art und Weise,
das herauszufinden, ist es,
andere Orte anzuschauen,
wo Leben entstehen kann,
z.B. den frühen Mars oder
Gebiete im äusseren Sonnensystem
oder andere Planeten
um andere Sterne.
(Frau über Lautsprecher)
EDL nav 2 has been initiated.
The star tracker
has been powered off.
Einen der bisher aufregendsten
Momente seiner Karriere
hatte Zurbuchen am 26. November 2018.
Die Landung der Weltraumsonde InSight
auf dem Mars.
Nach einer sechsmonatigen Reise
und rund 300 Mio. Meilen
durch das Weltall
hat die Raumsonde InSight
ihr Ziel erreicht:
den roten Planeten Mars.
Auf dem Mars zu landen
ist immer schwierig.
Über die Hälfte der Versuche
sind gescheitert.
In einer halben Stunde
ist die Landung.
Menschen weltweit
schauen dem Ereignis live zu.
Es gibt an vielen Orten
watch parties,
sogar vor der Küste von Madagaskar.
Wir wissen:
Wir gehen ein grosses Risiko ein.
Aber Tatsache ist:
Wir tun es vor allen Kameras.
Wir glauben daran.
Wenn unsere Arbeit
Menschen weltweit inspirieren soll,
müssen wir den Mut haben,
zu zeigen, dass es schwierig ist,
und sogar zu zeigen,
dass es manchmal nicht funktioniert.
* Tiefe, sphärische Klänge *
Diese Computeranimation zeigt,
wie die Landung aussehen könnte.
Standing by for parachute deploy.
Nach dem Eintritt
in die Mars-Atmosphäre
wird der Roboter
mithilfe von Fallschirm
und Bremsraketen abgesenkt.
Ein hoch riskantes Manöver.
Altitude 600 m.
Gravity turn, altitude 400 m.
Einerseits
ist es unglaublich stressig,
andererseits unglaublich schön.
Die Frage ist:
Gehen die letzten 7 Min. gut?
7 Min.: So lange
sind die Steuerungsbefehle
vom Kontrollzentrum
bis zum Landemodul unterwegs.
Man kann nichts mehr tun.
Er fliegt auf den Mars.
Das Einzige, das wir hoffen,
ist, dass er landet,
mit all den Systemen, die wir hier
und an anderen Orten getestet haben,
und keinen Krater macht.
200 m.
80 m.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Touchdown confirmed.
Auf dem Mars zu landen
ist unglaublich viel schwieriger
als alle andere Landungen.
Wenn es nicht geklappt hätte,
was hätte das bedeutet?
Ich hatte alle Reden bereit.
Wir wären vor die Kameras gestanden
und hätten gesagt:
"Was wir tun, ist schwierig.
Und ab und zu klappt es nicht."
"Wir werden daraus lernen
und zurückkommen."
Wie viel Geld
hätten Sie in den Sand gesetzt?
700 Mio.
Probleme gibt es aber durchaus:
Die Bodenbeschaffenheit auf dem Mars
ist offenbar ganz anders
als erwartet.
Ein Instrument des InSight-Roboters,
genannt hämmernder Maulwurf,
hätte für Messungen
bis zu 5 m tief gelangen sollen.
Bis jetzt hat man aber
nur wenige Zentimeter geschafft.
Man sagt, das Weltall ist unendlich.
Wo hört in Ihrer Vorstellungskraft
das Universum auf?
Für mich ...
Ich bin auch ein Mensch
wie alle anderen.
Für mich gibt es Grenzen
der Vorstellungskraft.
Bei der Umgebung des Weltalls
denke ich daran,
dass es nicht aufhört.
Ich stelle mir vor,
wie ich frei falle
und für immer frei falle.
Auch wenn ich mein ganzes Leben und
das Alter des Universums frei falle,
bin ich nicht am Ende
des Universums.
Und was ist der freie Fall
für ein Gefühl?
Ein Gefühl von Freiheit, aber auch
ein Gefühl von Unendlichkeit.
Wirklich gehen lassen.
Das Universum ist für mich
so viel mächtiger als alles,
was wir uns vorstellen können.
Bei einem unserer Experimente
schauten wir per Teleskop
zur dunkelsten Stelle des Himmels.
Wir stellten es hin und warteten
und sammelten tagelang Licht.
In diesem Bereich,
einem ganz kleinen Winkel,
haben wir
über 6'000 neue Galaxien gefunden.
Wohin wir am Himmel auch schauen,
gibt es Tausende Galaxien,
die unser Auge nicht sehen kann.
Das Universum ist viel reicher,
als wir je gedacht haben.
Überall, in jedem Winkel des
Himmels, gibt es Tausende Galaxien.
Hm.
Zurbuchen hat seit Jahren
auch den amerikanischen Pass.
In der Schweiz ist er meist
nur mehr zu Besuch.
Aber auch in dieser Zeit
ist der Astrophysiker fast ständig
als NASA-Missionar unterwegs.
Z.B. an der ETH Zürich.
Hier bei einem Auftritt
zusammen mit dem Schweizer
Astronauten Claude Nicollier.
Es ist absolut ausverkauft. Toll.
- Okay, super.
Es ist fast die letzte Woche
vor Weihnachten,
die Studierenden
haben zwar Deadlines,
aber sie kommen, weil sie wissen,
dass Prof. Nicollier
und Prof. Dr. Thomas Zurbuchen
hier sind.
Er ist
ein unglaublicher Kommunikator.
Darauf freuen wir uns.
Auch hier ist die Landung
der Mars-Mission InSight ein Thema.
Die ETH hatte dafür
an geophysikalischen Instrumenten
mitgearbeitet.
Touchdown confirmed.
Menschen wie ihr
können in guten Teams
solche unglaublichen Dinge schaffen.
Dinge,
die noch nie jemand erreicht hat.
Darum geht es.
So entdecken wir die neuen Ufer
des kosmischen Ozeans.
So gehen wir ins All - immer tiefer.
Auftritt an einem Berner Gymnasium.
Zurbuchen redet
über den Nutzen von Wettersatelliten.
Z.B. wenn grosse Wirbelstürme
im Anmarsch sind,
wie Hurrikan Florence 2018
in den USA.
Tatsache ist: Dieser Sturm
hat Hunderte Menschen getötet.
Und ohne unsere Voraussage
wären Zehntausende Menschen
getötet worden.
An der Uni Bern
wird er mit einem Preis geehrt.
Ein ehemaliger Lehrer nennt
eines von Zurbuchens Erfolgsrezepten:
das Networking.
Er hat schon immer gewusst,
wie man mit den richtigen Leuten
die richtigen Beziehungen eingeht.
- Ist das wahr? - Ja, ich finde.
Zurbuchens Auftritte haben stets
etwas Amerikanisches an sich -
auch dann,
wenn er schweizerdeutsch spricht.
Was macht eigentlich
der Forschungsdirektor der NASA?
Im Wesentlichen
habe ich von 8-19 Uhr Meetings.
Jede halbe Stunde
kommt jemand für ein Treffen.
Das mache ich.
Aber was ich wirklich mache:
Ich habe 107 Missionen.
Einige fliegen,
einige entwickeln wir.
Ich bin zuständig
für jede wichtige Entscheidung:
ob wir sie machen,
ins All schiessen, ausschalten.
All diese Entscheidungen
kommen zu mir.
Ich bin unglaublich froh,
dort zu sein.
Hoffentlich sagt niemand,
ich sei als Berner zu langsam.
Herr Zurbuchen, gibt es für Sie
den Satz: "Es geht nicht."
Das Wort "Nein" mag ich nicht.
* Lachen *
Ich hasse es.
Wenn man eine Mauer vor mich stellt,
versuche ich, reinzurennen,
darum herum, unten durch ...
- Der Oberländer Dickschädel.
Aber "Nein, das können wir nicht",
gibt es nicht.
Vielleicht "noch nicht".
Aber ein Nein akzeptiere ich nicht.
* Geheimnisvolle Klänge *
Ein seltener Besuch in seinem
Geburtsort Heiligenschwendi.
Hier ist er in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Wie ist es für Sie hier?
- (Frau) I love to visit.
(Mit amerikanischem Akzent)
Es ist schön, hier zu sein.
Es ist wunderschön.
Es ist total anders,
als ich aufgewachsen bin.
Total anders.
- Chicago.
Ja, in der Nähe von Chicago.
Meinen Sie,
er ist geprägt durch das hier?
Geprägt.
- Was ist geprägt?
Do you think, he was formed by this?
- Ah!
Yeah, definitely. Absolutely.
Oh ja, ganz sicher.
Er ist, wer er ist,
weil er hier aufgewachsen ist.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich denke, bei aller Liebe, dass
Thomas ein recht sturer Mensch ist.
Er ist einer, der sich durchsetzt
und selten nachgibt.
Er weiss, wohin er will
und wie er dort ankommt.
Er gibt nicht auf.
Ich denke, das kommt von der Zeit,
als er noch hier oben lebte.
Ein paar 100 m weiter unten
ging ich zur Schule,
in die 1.-4. Klasse.
Die ersten zwei Jahre
waren etwas hart.
Ich konnte schon lesen
und die Lehrerin wusste nicht,
was sie damit anfangen sollte.
Aber dann ...
V.a. haben wir einander verprügelt,
die Bauernbuben und wir.
Das war
eine ziemlich interessante Zeit.
Wie meinen Sie das?
Untereinander oder gegen Sie?
Untereinander.
Ich war halt einer der Grössten.
Gegen mich schon.
Aber ich war auch immer der,
der hier Probleme schuf.
Ich weiss nicht,
es war mir einfach langweilig.
Vier Jahre ging ich hier zur Schule
und dann nach Hünibach.
Jeden Tag hinuntergegangen.
Durch den Nebel und an den See.
Und dann ...
Das war nicht gut.
In Hünibach gibt es reiche Leute,
aber wir hier oben
waren nicht reich.
Das war schwierig.
An einem Elternabend
sagte mal ein Lehrer:
"Die Leute dort oben
sind nicht unglaublich intelligent."
"Schau nur die Eltern an,
dann siehst du,
dass sie nicht schlau sind."
Die Schüler merkten auch,
dass die Lehrer so dachten.
War das eine Motivation
für das Leben? - Ja, absolut.
* Sanfte, mystische Klänge *
Der grösste Schritt für mich
war der ans Gymnasium.
Niemand in meiner Umgebung
ging ans Gymnasium.
Als ich meinem Sekundarlehrer sagte,
ich wolle ans Gymnasium,
riet er mir davon ab.
Ich sei wohl
nicht intelligent genug.
Als ich dann Uni-Professor war,
habe ich übrigens in der Käserei
mal eine Karte für ihn abgegeben.
"Mit vielen Grüssen."
Aber Tatsache war:
Als ich dann ins Gymnasium kam,
habe ich so viele Dinge gelernt,
über Geschichte,
über andere Menschen,
über andere Schicksale.
Das war ein riesiger
mentaler Schritt für mich.
Der Schritt nach Thun
war für mich viel grösser
als der von Thun nach Amerika.
* Sanfte Streichmusik *
Es war eine schöne Kindheit
in einer kleinen Umgebung.
Ich kannte alle.
Wenn ich einen Stein warf,
den ich nicht hätte werfen dürfen,
wussten das meine Eltern schon,
bevor ich nach Hause kam.
Wer es gesehen hatte,
rief meine Eltern an.
Alle haben auf uns aufgepasst.
Meine Familie war sehr religiös.
Mein Vater
war Evangelist in einer Freikirche.
Aber ich wusste schon
als kleiner Junge,
dass ich von dort weggehen würde.
Ich schaute die Sterne an
und stellte mir vor,
wie das wohl aussieht,
wenn ich die Sterne
von einem anderen Ort aus betrachte.
Von wo aus auf der Erde auch immer.
Als er von hier oben wegging
und einen Weg als Wissenschaftler
einschlug,
folgte auch eine innere Distanz
zu seiner Familie.
Auch die Beziehung zu seinem Bruder
und den beiden Schwestern
habe darunter gelitten.
Nicht zuletzt, weil Thomas die
religiöse Gemeinschaft seines Vaters
verliess und den Gottesdiensten,
den sog. Versammlungen, fernblieb.
Seine Eltern hätten seine Karriere
nicht aktiv behindert,
aber diese oft nicht verstanden.
Mit seinem Vater
sei es erst kurz vor dessen Tod
zu einer Aussöhnung gekommen.
Jahrelang
hatten Sie keinen Kontakt mehr.
Nein, ich war selten hier.
Jede Generation
hat dasselbe Problem. Die Frage ist:
Tun die Kinder das,
was die Eltern wollen?
Sie taten das nicht. - Absolut nicht.
Ich bin das verlorene Schaf.
War das Problem, dass Sie weggingen
oder dass Sie Wissenschaftler wurden?
Es gehört alles zusammen.
Es war das Weglaufen vom Zentrum.
Das Zentrum
in einer solchen Gemeinde ist hier,
das religiöse Zentrum
mit meinem Vater war hier,
das Lebenszentrum war hier.
Davor weglaufen bedeutet für viele
ein Leugnen dessen, was man ist.
Das ist eine negative Sache.
Alles ist so aufgebaut,
dass man aufeinander aufpasst.
Alles ist positiv,
hier ist es am schönsten.
Wieso sollte man irgendwohin?
Hier ist es doch am Schönsten.
Mein Leben passte einfach nicht
hier herein, in allen Dimensionen.
Die Umgebung,
die religiöse Dimension ...
Alles war etwas schwieriger.
Ich stellte vielleicht
zu viele Fragen.
Oder die falschen.
- Ja, die falschen Fragen.
Wissenschaftler sind Zweifler,
von Anfang an.
Sie zweifeln an allem.
Wissenschaftler sind nicht gläubig,
sie sind Zweifler.
Und die Umgebung hier
war eher für Gläubige.
Zurbuchen zu Besuch
in seinem Elternhaus.
Was ich erst später erfahre:
Seine Mutter leidet hier bereits
an einer Krebserkrankung.
Tschau, tschau.
- Hallo.
Du musst sagen, was du willst
und was du nicht willst.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ja, so hat er immer geschlafen.
Schläft er heute noch so?
Das war das Beste, als du Daniela
Watte in die Finken gelegt hast
und Stecknadeln reingesteckt hast.
- Oh.
Er ist ...
* Lachen *
Innovativ.
Aber eigentlich ist er feinfühlig.
Sehr feinfühlig.
- Okay.
Aber äusserlich
sieht man es nicht gleich.
Er ist gut.
Wir verstanden uns gut. Gell?
Ja, absolut.
Ist das dort hinten der Vater?
- Ja, genau.
Er ist dieses Jahr gestorben.
450 Menschen kamen zur Beerdigung.
Und alle sagten, er habe ihr Leben
auf eine positive Art verändert.
Er und ich hatten nicht immer
die gleiche Meinung.
Aber wenn an meiner Beerdigung mal
450 Menschen sagen,
ich hätte in ihrem Leben etwas Gutes
getan, ist das ein Erfolg.
Lustigerweise
sagte mein Chef in Amerika mal:
"Das hörst du nicht gern,
aber ich sage es jetzt trotzdem:"
"Deine Hauptstärken
sind die deines Vaters."
"In allem anderen, wissenschaftlich,
bist du gut
und es gibt viele Leute,
die auch so gut sind."
"Aber was dein Vater hat,
wie er Leute hinter sich bringen
und motivieren kann,
das ist es, was dich ausmacht."
Ich hatte wirklich immer
Respekt vor ihm, mein ganzes Leben.
Er hatte ein grosses Herz.
Es gibt viele religiöse Führer,
die falsch sind.
Vor der Kamera oder auf der Kanzel
sind sie eine Person,
dann gehen sie nach Hause
und sind totale Arschlöcher.
Er nicht. Er war authentisch und
immer derselbe, auf der Kanzel ...
Er war immer gleich
und versuchte, das Beste zu tun.
Daran ist er manchmal
fast verzweifelt.
Manchmal war es schwierig,
auch für dich,
weil er so oft weg war.
- Ja, er war fast nie hier.
Er hatte manchmal wenig Zeit
für unsere vier Kinder.
Er war ja immer den ganzen Sommer
mit dem Zelt unterwegs.
Und auch sonst unterwegs.
- Mit dem Zelt?
Missionszelt.
- Was heisst das?
Das war ein Zelt mit Plane
und einer Orgel drin,
mitten auf der Wiese eines Bauern.
Am Sonntag verteilten wir manchmal
im ganzen Dorf Einladungen.
Wir sagten:
"Kommt und hört über Herrn Jesus."
Oft kamen die Leute
und er predigte dort jeden Abend.
War es fürs soziale Prestige kein
Plus, der Sohn des Pfarrers zu sein?
Nicht immer.
- Nein, es war viel schwieriger.
Für Thomas
war es fast am schwierigsten.
Gell, Thomas? - Ganz im Gegenteil.
* Hilda lacht. *
Es wäre einfacher gewesen,
wenn es nicht so gewesen wäre.
Für unseren Sohn Lukas
war es ganz anders.
Ja, er war von Anfang an heilig.
* Erin lacht. *
Ich hätte es nicht ausgehalten
mit euch,
wenn es noch einen Zweiten wie dich
gegeben hätte.
Ich sage immer:
Wenn man ein Gehege mit Schafen
und einem Brunnen anschaut,
liegen viele Schafe
einfach um den Brunnen herum.
Und ein Schaf ist immer am Zaun.
Das war ich. Immer am Zaun.
Ich versuchte,
das Loch nach draussen zu finden.
Aber ich mache das nicht extra.
Ich stehe morgens nicht auf
und denke:
Jetzt muss ich eine Grenze suchen
und weitergehen.
Ich ging nicht zur NASA,
weil ich immer zur NASA wollte.
Ich habe drei, vier ...
Ich war erfolgreich als Professor,
in der Führung einer Universität,
ich war dort
in der ganzen Umgebung bekannt.
Dann hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich lerne nichts mehr. Oder wenig.
Dann begann ich den Leuten zu sagen:
Ich suche eine Stelle.
Am Schluss
hatte ich zwei offene Stellen:
eine für Amazon,
mit Jeff Bezos arbeiten,
als Innovationschef,
und die andere:
als Forschungschef bei der NASA.
Ganz unterschiedliche Stellen.
Aber bei beiden Stellen
kann man lernen,
Dinge lernen,
die ich noch nicht wusste.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome the Vice President
of the United States
and the chair of the
National Space Council: Mike Pence.
Die amerikanische Raumfahrtbehörde
NASA ist allerdings oft auch
ein Spielball der Politik.
Präsident Trump und sein Vize Mike
Pence geben ehrgeizige Pläne vor.
Thank you all.
Die Vereinigten Staaten
sind seit jeher eine Nation
von ruhelosen Pionieren,
die immer danach streben,
neue Horizonte zu erreichen.
Vor 50 Jahren war ein
kleiner Schritt für einen Menschen
ein grosser Schritt
für die Menschheit.
Jetzt ist aber
die Zeit für uns gekommen
für den nächsten grossen Schritt.
Wir wollen wieder amerikanische
Astronauten auf den Mond schicken.
Sie sollen auf dem Mond
eine ständige Basis errichten
und Technologien entwickeln, die
dann Amerikaner zum Mars bringen -
und darüber hinaus.
Astronauten auf dem Mond
und dem Mars?
Eine riesige Herausforderung.
Hier in Kalifornien
ist das Forschungszentrum der NASA
für Mars-Missionen.
Über 5'000 Frauen und Männer
arbeiten in diesem streng bewachten
Territorium für die Raumfahrtbehörde.
Ein neuer Mars-Rover soll im Juli
ins Weltall geschickt werden.
Eine heikle Mission, auch
für Wissenschaftsdirektor Zurbuchen.
Darum fliegt er regelmässig
von Washington nach Kalifornien.
Ist das der Rover?
- Yeah. So that's a model.
Ist das der, den es schon gibt?
- Das ist der, der auf dem Mars ist.
Also Curiosity. Das ist der Rover.
Der, den wir gerade bauen,
sieht ähnlich aus,
es sind aber
ganz andere Instrumente drauf.
In steriler Umgebung arbeiten
die Techniker am neuesten Mars-Rover.
Dieser soll u.a. Bodenproben nehmen
und in Behälter abfüllen.
Diese Behälter sollen eines Tages
von einem Raumschiff
auf die Erde zurückgebracht werden.
Es wäre die erste Rückreise vom Mars.
Auch Europa, China
und die Arabischen Emirate
wollen dieses Jahr
Mars-Missionen starten.
Die Zeit ist knapp.
Klappt es im Juli nicht
mit dem Raketenstart,
muss man zwei Jahre warten.
Erst dann stehen Erde und Mars
wieder so günstig zueinander.
Betreffend der fehlenden Teile:
Ich habe gehört, dass die Franzosen
demnächst liefern können?
Die Auslieferungsüberprüfung
in Frankreich
findet am Montag oder Dienstag
statt.
Das System
fürs Absetzen des Helikopters
sollte auch in ein paar Wochen
eintreffen.
Darf ich da nachfragen?
Gestern wurde mir gesagt,
dass diese Helikopterteile
bereits geliefert worden sind.
Warum sagen Sie, in ein paar Wochen?
Es wurde von Lockheed Martin
verschickt und ist eingetroffen.
Aber die Teile
müssten noch ausgepackt werden.
Sorry. I was slowing you.
- No problem.
I apologize.
Hey guys.
Wann ist eure Schicht?
- (Mann) Um 14 Uhr.
Ah, ihr fangt jetzt gleich an.
Und wann seid ihr fertig?
Wir arbeiten von 14.30 Uhr
bis um 23 Uhr.
Okay, und die nächste Schicht?
Morgen um 7 Uhr geht es dann weiter.
Das nimmt euren ganzen Alltag ein.
- Ja, das tut's.
Danke für eure Arbeit.
Das ist wirklich cool. Alright.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Ich frage mich: Wozu braucht
die Menschheit solche Projekte?
Die Forschung, die der Roboter
macht, sobald er auf dem Mars ist,
beantwortet Fragen,
die wir seit Tausenden von Jahren
zu beantworten versuchen.
Die Frage lautet: Woher kommt Leben?
Das ist eine der Fragen,
die wir mit dieser Maschine
beantworten können.
Wahrscheinlich nicht
die ganze Frage, aber Teile davon.
Gab es auf der Oberfläche des Mars
früher Leben?
Das ist eine der wichtigen Fragen
der Menschheit.
Wäre es nicht wichtiger, z.B. für den
Klimawandel mehr Mittel einzusetzen?
Absolut, wir haben gerade
eine Mission angeschaut,
bei der wir das Klima untersuchen.
Insbesondere den Wasserstand
auf der Oberfläche,
aber auch das Trinkwasser
auf der ganzen Erde.
Wir wollen beides machen,
nicht nur den Mars, auch die Erde.
Umstritten ist die Frage,
ob man wirklich Menschen
auf den Mars schicken soll.
Stand jetzt würde das
mehrere 100 Mrd. Fr. kosten.
Das dürfte also noch Jahre dauern.
Immerhin: Der neue Rover
soll Erkenntnisse darüber liefern,
welche Gefahren
und Gesundheitsrisiken
es auf dem Mars für Menschen gibt.
* Mystische, glockige Klänge *
Luna, come! Let's go.
Ein nobles Wohngebiet
im Bundesstaat Virginia.
Hier wohnen die Zurbuchens.
So wie viele hohe Beamte,
die im nahegelegenen Washington, D.C.
arbeiten.
Zurbuchens Frau Erin
ist Lehrerin und Musikerin.
Sie haben zwei Kinder,
Lukas und Maria.
Thomas sei ein fordernder Vater,
sagt seine Frau über ihn.
Haben Sie die Kinder so erzogen,
wie Sie das Personal führen?
Das wäre eine gute Frage
für meine Kinder.
Ich hoffe nicht,
aber sie denken schon.
Es war lustig:
Als ich wegging von Michigan,
standen die Leute hin
und hielten Reden über mich.
Einige sagten: "Es ist
unglaublich schwierig mit dem Kerl."
"Denn er lässt dich nie in Ruhe."
"Es ist schwierig."
"Er ist nie wirklich zufrieden."
Und das ist wahr.
Ich bin nie wirklich zufrieden.
Dann stand mein Sohn auf
und sagte dasselbe.
"Immer, wenn ich ein Ziel erreiche,
nennt er mir das nächste Ziel."
Ja.
- Das mache ich nicht bewusst.
Ehrlich gesagt war das
ein Schlag in den Magen.
Tatsache ist:
Ich merke es nicht mal.
Ich bin so gebaut.
Aber ich habe nicht gemerkt,
dass ich es mit den Kindern mache.
Mir hat geholfen ...
Ich sagte zu Erin:
"Du musst mir helfen."
Und sie sagte:
"Ja, es ist sehr wichtig,
dass du nur über das sprichst,
was sie gerade gemacht haben,
und nicht über etwas anderes."
* Fröhliches Klavierstück:
"Oh! Susanna" von Stephen Foster *
* Bellen *
Er hat gerade die Staats-
meisterschaften gewonnen im Rudern.
Ja, schade,
haben wir das nicht filmen können.
Es war so toll,
ihn gewinnen zu sehen.
Bist du der Steuermann?
Nein, er ist zu kräftig dafür.
Zurbuchens Sohn Lukas
und Tochter Maria
waren nicht sehr begeistert
über unsere Filmaufnahmen.
Sie tun sich noch etwas schwer damit,
dass ihr Vater
inzwischen zur Prominenz gehört.
I think, both are ambitious.
Unsere Kinder
sind beide sehr ehrgeizig.
Aber sie wollen unabhängig sein.
- Exactly.
Maria hat doch einmal
ein ausgezeichnetes
Wissenschaftsvideo gemacht
zum Thema Schwarze Löcher.
Und Thomas wollte es auf seinem
Twitter-Account veröffentlichen.
Maria sagte: "Auf keinen Fall!"
Sie wollte nicht, dass ihr Video
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
einen Bezug zu ihrem Vater hatte.
Und du hattest das akzeptiert.
Die Kinder
wollen das Beste erreichen,
aber sie wollen es alleine tun.
Der Job bringt es mit sich,
dass ihr Vater auch an Sonntagen
ans Geschäft denken muss.
Z.B. wenn Präsident Trump
wieder einmal auf Twitter aktiv ist.
Und damit Verwirrung stiftet,
so auch in Zusammenhang
mit der geplanten Mond-Mission.
No, no problem, absolutely not.
I just felt so bad.
Ein Tweet hat gestern
unser Leben verändert.
Der Tag war viel aufregender,
als irgendjemand gedacht hätte.
"Mit all dem Geld, das wir ausgeben,
sollte die NASA
nicht darüber sprechen,
wieder zum Mond zu gehen."
"Das haben wir
vor 50 Jahren gemacht."
"Sie sollte sich
auf grössere Dinge fokussieren,
z.B. auf den Mars."
He tweeted ...
Trump fragte auf einmal, wieso wir
wieder auf den Mond wollen.
Man solle doch zum Mars.
- "Just go to Mars."
Der Präsident
hat diesen Tweet verschickt.
Ich war gerade in einem Meeting. Und
alle fragten: "Was tun wir jetzt?"
Ist das so bei seinen Tweets?
Sofort fliegt eine Tür auf und
einer sagt: "Level nine emergency".
Genau so, mit diesen Worten.
* Treibende Klänge *
In solchen Fällen
liegt es oft an Thomas Zurbuchen,
im amerikanischen Parlament
für Klarheit zu sorgen.
Und zu erklären, für was genau
die amerikanischen Steuerzahlenden
der NASA jährlich
über 20 Mrd. Fr. gewähren.
Ein paar Tage nach Trumps Tweet
ist Zurbuchen bei einer Subkommission
des Kongresses vorgeladen.
Guten Morgen.
Bevor wir beginnen,
möchte ich sagen,
dass es für mich wirklich
eine Freude und eine Ehre ist,
diese Subkommission zu leiten.
Unsere Investitionen im All
und in die Raumfahrt
sind Katalysatoren für Wachstum,
Entdeckungen und Innovation
in Amerika.
Aber wir müssen aufpassen,
dass die NASA
auch beim Kostenmanagement
so innovativ ist
wie bei den
wissenschaftlichen Entdeckungen.
We will start today
with Dr. Zurbuchen. Dr. Zurbu...
Zurbuchen.
- Alle nennen mich Dr. Z.
Chair Horn, ranking member Babin, es
freut mich, heute hier auszusagen.
Wir wollen bis ins Jahr 2024
Menschen auf den Mond schicken
und von dort bis 2028
eine nachhaltige Präsenz aufbauen.
Damit schaffen wir
die Voraussetzungen
für die Erforschung des Planeten
Mars durch Menschen vor Ort,
das ultimative Ziel
dieses NASA-Programms.
Bitte, 5 Min. für Herrn Olson.
Danke, Vorsitzende,
und ein grosses Texas-Willkommen
für unsere Experten.
Könnten Sie mir erklären, warum wir
zuerst auf den Mond gehen müssen,
um schneller auf den Mars zu kommen?
Das ist eine wichtige Frage,
die Sie stellen.
Es gibt
einen fundamentalen Unterschied,
ob man noch in der Erdumlaufbahn ist
oder im Weltall.
Das hat mit der Strahlung
dort draussen zu tun.
Man muss für längere Zeit in diesem
Strahlungsumfeld leben können,
wenn man auf den Mars will.
Und genau das können wir
auf der Oberfläche des Mondes üben.
Unser ultimatives Ziel ist,
von den natürlichen Ressourcen
auf dem Mond und dem Mars
leben zu können, Wasser z.B.
Ressourcen,
die eines Tages vielleicht
von Firmen abgebaut werden können.
Das gäbe neue Geschäftsmodelle.
Das ist positiv.
Wir wären nicht
in den Vereinigten Staaten,
dem Land, das wir lieben,
wenn die Menschen vor uns
nicht auch so gedacht hätten.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ten, nine, eight, seven ...
- And the final seconds.
Six, five, four, three,
two, one, zero.
And liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket
and Dragon spacecraft,
carrying research seeking to improve
human health on earth and in space.
Bei diesem Raketenstart in Florida
Anfang Mai
hätte auch Thomas Zurbuchen
mit vor Ort sein sollen.
Und wir mit ihm.
Aber das Schicksal wollte es anders.
Und wir trafen uns stattdessen
wieder in Heiligenschwendi.
Es war ein trauriger Tag.
Am Mittwochabend
habe ich einen Anruf bekommen.
Es war meine Mutter.
Sie hatte den ganzen Tag gesagt,
sie müsse mit mir reden.
Wir haben nochmal geredet und
zwei Tage später ist sie gestorben.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Was meinen Sie:
Wo ist Ihre Mutter jetzt?
Ja ... Also ich habe ...
Ich habe ...
Ich weiss, dass sie daran glaubte,
dass sie jetzt bei meinem Vater ist.
Über Ostern im Himmel. Ich bin
sicher, dass sie das glaubte.
Ich weiss es nicht, aber ich hoffe
und glaube, dass sie recht hatte.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie man solche Fragen beantwortet.
Der Grund ist ...
Jedes Mal, wenn ich
in die Natur schaue, denke ich:
Es gibt einen Gott.
Aber bei allem,
das mit Erfahrungen zu tun hat,
für die es in keinster Weise
einen Beweis gibt, habe ich Zweifel.
Nicht in einem schlechten Sinn.
Ich akzeptiere,
dass sie das glaubte.
Und ich bin 100 % sicher, dass
für sie das Richtige passiert ist,
dass sie bei Vater ist,
genau dort, wo sie hinwollte,
bei Leuten, die sie vermisst hat,
bei ihrem Vater, ihrer Mutter,
ihren Tanten.
Ich hoffe, dass es genau so ist.
Tschau, Manfred.
Ich bin schon wieder hier
für eine Beerdigung.
So ist es. Mein herzliches Beileid.
- Danke.
Salut.
- Danke, Tschau.
Bist du rechtzeitig gekommen?
- Ja, aber nicht vor ihrem Tod.
Sie hat mich zwei Tage vorher
noch angerufen.
Sie hat sich gewehrt,
sie wollte nicht gehen.
Sie wollte es sehr privat halten,
nicht mal eine Anzeige
im Dorf verschicken.
Ja, aber sterben
ist schliesslich keine Schande.
Früher oder später trifft es jeden.
- Es trifft jeden. Es ist so.
Haben Sie seinen Vater auch gekannt?
- Ja, gut.
Den Onkel kannte ich noch besser,
der war Störmetzger,
sein Onkel Fritz.
- Aha.
Mit ihm war ich oft unterwegs.
Er war mehr so ...
Er war auch in der Musik.
Das ging jeweils zu und her.
Er mochte die Fässchen.
Mein Vater und sein Bruder
waren ungleich.
Er war ein Lustiger.
- Mein Vater war viel ernsthafter.
Ja, ja, ich kannte ihn schon.
Kann ich Ihnen etwas anbieten?
Ich würde Ihnen gern
ein Glas Wein geben.
Grüessech, guten Tag.
Schön, dich mal so zu sehen.
- Super, ja.
Tschau, Christian.
- Hallo.
Ich kondoliere von ganzem Herzen.
- Vielen Dank.
Ich habe diese Karte geschrieben,
die ich heute einwerfen wollte.
Das ist aber lieb.
Meine Mutter ist gestorben.
Ja, ich schreibe auch gerade.
- Das ist lieb.
Thomas!
- Zum Wohl, Gesundheit.
Verfolgen Sie die Karriere
von Herrn Zurbuchen?
Ja, klar, wir waren zusammen
in der Feuerwehr, im Atemschutz.
Genau, und im Militär natürlich.
Ja, im Militär.
Du warst Funkeroffizier.
Und du warst Grenadier.
- Nein, ich war Infanterist.
Aber ich kam an deinen Besuchstag
und du kamst an meinen.
Ja, das ist so.
Das war es ungefähr.
Man interessierte sich füreinander.
Wird er mal Ehrenbürger?
Was bräuchte es?
Ja ... Ich weiss nicht.
- Gute Frage.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Eine gute Frage.
Haben wir überhaupt Ehrenbürger?
Es gab noch nie einen.
Vielleicht ist eben auch
die Tugend Bescheidenheit
eine Tugend.
Er ist ein berühmter Mann,
der Trump trifft
und für Milliarden
Raketen in den Himmel schickt usw.
Ähm ...
Das ist tipptopp
und man kann stolz darauf sein,
dass jemand von hier das kann.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es so:
Es gibt viele Leute,
die tolle Jobs machen.
Der Dorfdoktor, der vielen Leuten
zu einem längeren Leben verhilft,
ist genau gleich viel wert wie er.
Es ist interessant, die Kultur
in verschiedenen Umgebungen.
In der Schweiz
sind zu Beginn alle gleich.
Das ist eine gute Sache, darüber
will ich nichts Negatives sagen.
Jeder ist gleich,
das ist genau so.
Dort, wo ich jetzt wohne,
ist es eher so:
Wenn jemand
etwas Spektakuläres macht,
sagen alle: "Der ist super."
Nach einigen Kollegen
auf meiner Stufe
sind Schulen benannt.
Die haben ihre Schulen.
Dann wäre das hier
die Thomas-Zurbuchen-Schule?
Ja, genau.
* Leise Gespräche *
* Melancholische Klavier-
und Streichmusik *
Es ist Sommer in Bern.
Zurbuchen ist für mehrere Vorträge
an seine ehemalige Uni gekommen.
Er trifft dabei auch seinen Bruder
Lukas, Chefgärtner in Bern.
Er wohnt noch im Elternhaus
in Heiligenschwendi.
Thomas Zurbuchen ist der Mann
des Tages in den Berner Zeitungen.
Haben Sie es gesehen? - Ja,
ich habe es der Familie geschickt.
Ja, er hat es mir geschickt.
Ich sagte: "Offenbar darf ich heute
keinen Bus nehmen."
Wenn mein Gesicht im Bus hängt ...
Wie ist das für Sie?
Sie hatten als Familie
eher ein ruhiges Leben,
sogar etwas zurückgezogen.
Jetzt ist der Bruder in den Medien
und damit auch
die ganze Familie und die Geschichte.
Das war eigentlich
schon immer ein wenig so.
Du bist schon immer
eher nach aussen orientiert.
Ich war eher zurückhaltend
und so ist es noch heute.
Ich will nicht ins Rampenlicht,
das gehört ihm.
Wenn die Geschichte von früher
erzählt wird,
gehören wir am Rand dazu,
aber sonst ist es gut so,
wie es ist.
Was hat sich jetzt verändert?
Sie haben innert kurzer Zeit
beide Elternteile verloren,
Vater und Mutter.
Schweisst das zusammen oder
ist man zu weit voneinander entfernt?
Wir haben uns seither
noch nicht gesehen. - Nein.
Wir haben eine Familiengruppe,
in der wir uns ab und zu schreiben.
Per WhatsApp.
- Genau.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Es ist fast noch zu frisch.
Für mich ... Ich habe gemerkt,
dass es für mich ...
Ich habe mir überlegt,
was ich heute Morgen tue.
Ich dachte: Ich gehe doch kurz
nach Heiligenschwendi.
Ich gehe immer
Der Grund waren Mutter und Vater.
Ich gehe nach Heiligenschwendi?
Aber keiner ist dort.
Du arbeitest.
Dann gehe ich eben nicht.
Ich gehe erstmals
nicht nach Heiligenschwendi,
wenn ich in der Schweiz bin.
Bei uns im Haus wurde es ruhig.
Man hörte sie jeweils umhergehen.
Das ist schon speziell.
Jetzt müssen wir die Wohnung räumen.
Habt ihr sie schon ausgeräumt?
- Ja, schon fast ganz.
Über ihre Freikirche
und das Familienleben
möchte Lukas Zurbuchen
lieber nicht vor der Kamera reden.
Auch seine beiden Schwestern nicht.
Ist er nicht derjenige,
der ausgebrochen ist?
Das kann man so nicht sagen. Er hat
einfach einen anderen Weg gewählt.
Das war seine Entscheidung
und stimmte für ihn so.
Ich habe es damals
etwas anders gesehen.
Ich habe immer gehofft,
dass der Weg gut ist
und dass dich befriedigt,
was du tust.
Und das war so.
Er ging nach Amerika,
noch viel weiter weg.
Als wir irgendwann
in Italien in den Ferien waren,
das weiss ich noch, sagtest du:
"Ihr lest dann von mir."
Ich wusste gar nicht, worum es geht.
Es war der Job, den du jetzt hast.
Seine ältere Schwester sagte mir,
sie würde dafür beten,
dass Thomas wieder den Weg zurück
in die religiöse Gemeinschaft finde.
Am letzten Vortrag ihres Bruders
in Bern ist sie auch dabei.
Jetzt wirst du aufgenommen.
Wie fühlt sich das an?
Hör auf.
- Siehst du?
Zoom auf deinen Kopf.
Ich habe gesehen,
du bist mit Familie da.
Sorry, we should start.
- Alright, sounds great.
Mein Bruder und meine Schwester
sind da, jeweils mit einem Kind.
Liebe Anwesende, ich möchte Sie im
Namen des "Bund" herzlich begrüssen
zu diesem "'Der Bund' im Gespräch",
Sie im Saal
und auch alle,
die per Livestream dabei sind.
Wer weiss,
vielleicht hören heute Abend sogar
ein paar unbekannte Wesen
im Weltall zu,
weil sie aus erster Hand
mitbekommen wollen,
was wir Menschen noch so vorhaben
mit dem Mond, dem Mars
und anderen Destinationen.
Ein junger Mann in der vordersten
Reihe möchte eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie mir einen Tipp,
wie ich Astronaut werden kann?
Ich bin jetzt elf.
* Lachen, Applaus *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Liftoff.
* Schwere Streichmusik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020